[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد البعث شبح لا زال يحوم
فوق المشهد السياسي رغم مرور عقدين على
اسقاط نظام صدام حسين وهروبي واعدام
غالبيه قادته الذين حكموا او حكموا البلاد
لنحو 35 عاما هذا الملف تحول في العراق
استثمارا سياسيا واقتصاديا وشماعه تعلق
عليها كافه عمليات الاقصاء والتصفيه منذ
ايام تتوالى ردود الفعل المندده بسمح
الاردن لحزب البعث بممارسه نشاطه السياسي
تصدر حزب الدعوه الاسلاميه وزعيمه نور
الملكي تيار معارضه القرار الاردني
معتبرين اياه خطوه استفزازيه وعملا عدائيا
فيما رئيس الوزراء الاسبق يد علاوي سعد
الى التفريق بين حزب البعث وبين نظام صدام
حسين الذي وصفه بالديكتاتوري معارضه بعض
الكتل السياسيه في العراق والقريبه من
ايران لكل ما يخص حزب البعث وتمسكها
بقانون اشتفاثه غالبا ما تص في حقيقه ان
معظم هذه القوه باستثناء تيار الصدر دعمت
حزب البعث السوري واسهمت بشكل فاعل في عدم
تفكيك نظامه بعد الانتفاضه السوريه عام
2011 وشاركت معظم الفصائل المسلحه الشيعيه
الى جانب قوات النظام في حربه ضد خصومه
حتى انا زعيم حزب الدعوه نور المالكي
استقبل في بغداد مسؤول تنظيم البعث
العراقي جناح سوريا محمد رشاد الشيخ راضي
نائب رئيس الوزراء الاسبق صالح المطلق قال
ان حزب البعث في العراق محظور الان لكن
النظام السياسي الذي مضى عليه 20 عام وما
زال يخشى من حزب تم شتاته هو نظام لا
يستحق ان يقود العراق
اجتثاث البعث هيئه انشات في العراق على يد
الحاكم الاميركي
وفق قانون صدر عن سلطه الائتلاف المؤقته
يمنع بموجبه المنتمون للحزب من الترشح
للانتخابات نيل المناصب العليا في الحكومه
منع عوده حزب البعث فكرا واداره وسياسه
وممارسه تطهير مؤسسات القطاع الحكومي من
الموظفين البعثيين من ابرز المطالبين
بالغاء هذا القانون هي الكتل السنيه في
حين تحاول الكتل السياسيه القريبه من
ايران الابقاء عليه حتى تستخدمه ضد الخصوم
وينضم الينا من بغداد واثق الجبل البحث
السياسي ومن عمان سامح المعايطه وزير
الاعلام الاردني الاسبق اهلا بكما ضيفي
العزيزين واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من عمان مع
سميح المعيطم يعني سياده الوزير الاردني
اوضح موقفه من التصريح لحزب البعث لكن
نريد ان نسمع منك من جديد ولمن لم يسمع
موقف الاردن قبل ان نبدا هذا الحوار في اي
اطار جاءت هذه او جاء هذا التصريح
مساء الخير لحضرتك الكريم الحقيقه الاردن
الترخيص ليس في اطار اي شيء مرتبط بالعراق
وخليني اذكر مره اخرى هذا الحزب موجود
بالاردن منذ عشرات السنه وكانت كل الاحزاب
بالاردن محظوره بحكم الاحكام العرفيه قبل
التسعه
الغيت الاحكام العرفيه وتم وضع قانون
للاحزاب عام 92 تم ترخيص عشرات الاحزاب
الاردنيه بما فيها حزب البعث يعني هذا
الحكي تم بعام 1992 يعني قبل
حوالي 31 عام من اليوم في عام 22 كان في
عنا مبادره ملكيه للاصلاح السياسي تم على
ضوءها تعديل قانون الاحزاب الاردني وقانون
الانتخاب وتم اجراء تعديلات دستوريه وطلب
من كل الاحزاب القائمه او القديمه ان تكيف
وضح القانوني لانه كان في شروط جديده
بالقانون الجديد عليها ان تلتزم بالقانون
وتك مع الشروط الجديده اللي هي لها علاقه
بعدد الاعضاء المؤسسين ولا علاقه بنسبه
المراه ونسبه الشباب ولا علاقه بالانتشار
بالمحافظات يعني ما كان العلاقه اي قضايا
سياسيه فكل الاحزاب اللي كانت او اغلب
الاحزاب الموجوده واحزاب جديده تقدمت
للترخيص مره ثانيه على اساس القانون
الجديد واعطي التراخيص بما فيها حزب البعث
يعني ليس بالاردن سياق اسمه انتاج اعاده
انتاج حزب البعث مره اخرى او واضح مره
اخرى او دلاله ذلك الترخيص قانوني اردني
يعني استمرار لترخيص القطار القانوني وليس
حصرا على حزب البعث انما في اطار قانوني
واطار عام طيب سيد واثق الجابر السماء الى
خلينا دقيقه واحده اذا سمحت لي هو مرخص
كمان هو من عام 92 الحزب مرخص ويعمل وفق
القانون والدستور الاردني واعضاءه اردنيون
فقط لا غير طيب جيد سيد واثق لماذا ربما
تعتقدون بان الاردن قد يفتح الازمه مع
العراق برايكم هذا السبب هو السبب الحقيقي
الذي اثار تيارات قريبه من ايران في
العراق ام هناك اسباب خفيه اخرى
وجاء هذا القرار ليفجر هذا الحمق اذا ما
جاز التعبير
نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم وتحيلكم مشاهديكم
الكرام بطبيعه الحال العراق لا يتدخل يعني
في شؤون الاردن يعني في سواء في تاسيس
الاحزاب او اعطاء موافقات لكن ما يستفز
العراقيين انه هذا الحزب يعني عندما يعني
سمح له بممارسه العمل اول ما بدا برفع صور
رئيس النظام المقبور وما له من تاريخ اسود
يعني مع العراق هو اضر بكل المنطقه
الاقليميه والعراق ونظاما دمويًا حتى في
الاردن اضرب بطبيعه العلاقات وطبيعه
العلاقات مع دول الخليج والكويت والسعوديه
وغيرها من الدول بالتالي هذا النظام او او
هذا الحزب وارتباطه واصرار الحزب البعث في
الاردن على رفع صور رموز النظام السابق
هذا دليل على ان الحزب تاسس بارتباط
وباراده عراقيه وهي تندد وتهدد باسقاط
النظام السياسي العراقي وتتدخل في الشان
العراقي هو اذا كان حزبا الاردنيا فليبقى
حزبا الاردنيين الارد نيا ليس له علاقه
بالعراق ولا من حقه ان يستفز مشاعر
العراقيين بربط السؤال اسمح لي ان ادخل
الخط يعني هناك من يهدف في العراق يهتف
لصالح ايران وضد المصالح العراقيه ولم نرى
اي تحرك في العراق يعني ضد هؤلاء وبالتالي
هذه المقاربه التي تتحدث عنها تحدث في قلب
العاصمه العراقيه دون حسيب ولا رقيب
الدستور العراقي يشير الى ان حزب البعث
حزب اجرامي وحزب يعني ممنوع محظور يعني في
داخل العراق وتحضر كل تنظيماته واحنا حتى
هنالك قوانين نتحدث عن داخل نتحدث عن حزب
اردني وهو مسجل لدى الاردن واسمه حزب
البعث الاشتراك الاردني وهو يتحدث نعم هو
نعم هو في الداخل الاردني لكنه يتدخل في
الشيء العراقي ويرفع بشكل استفزازي صور
راس النظام المقبور وبالتالي
ان نرفع صور معارضيها داخل العراق نعم
استاذ سامي تفضل سيدي بعتقد انا يعني انا
بعتقد انه كيف تعال بالقصه من اللي اثروها
بالقبل ذلك وبعتقد انه السبب الاساسي ان
هنالك اطراف ليست معنيه بتطور العلاقات
الاردنيه العراقيه بشكل كبير او تطور
العلاقات العراقيه العربيه بشكل كبير
ولذلك بيتم الذهاب الى اي قضيه
وتضخيمها والنفخ فيها واعطاها ابعاد ليست
حقيقيه وليست موجوده حتى محاوله للتشويش
على العلاقات الاردنيه العراقيه بهذا
الموضوع احنا بالاردن الرئيس العراقي
السابق صدام حسين حاله بالعالم العربي
هنالك من يحبه ويمجد وهنالك من يكرهه
ويتحدث عنه بسلبيه هذا حالي بالعالم
العربي اليوم عندنا بموريتانيا على سبيل
المثال حزب بعث قوي يعني موجود فاحنا انا
اذا كان في اي احتجاج عرفت دول يا سيدي
غير عرف الاشخاص والمجموعات اذا كانت
الدوله العراقيه منزعجه من هذا الموضوع
هنالك مسار د والسياسي بين الدول مذكره من
الخارجيه
العراقيه الى السفاره الاردنيه او الى
الخارجيه الاردنيه تحتج فيها على هذا
الموضوع لكن اثاره الموضوع ومحاوله اعطاءه
بعد وكان الاردن يعادل العراق الاردن
الدوله التي وقفت مع العراق في كل المراحل
التي مرت والشعب العراقي احنا بالاردن
نقول هذا حصتنا هدول اخواننا واهلنا
ووقفنا معهم ووقفوا معنا والهم كل الكرامه
فانا بعتقد في محاوله لافتعال ازمه في
محاوله للتشويش على الاردن احنا بنعرف
جيدا انه هنالك تغيرت سياسيه في بعض
التيارات القليله في العراق ربما صوتها
يعني يكون اكثر سخبا وقفت ضد قضايا تعاون
مع الاردن في السنوات الماضيه كثيرا في
البرلمان وهذا ندركه لكن هنالك اصرار
اردني على تطوير العلاقات مع العراق لدينا
مصالح مشتركه موضوع الامن الارهاب
الاقتصاد فلذلك من يفعل ذلك هو الذي يسيء
الى العراق ويعطل مصالحه اذا في مواطنين
اردنيين في حزب رفعوا صوره صدام حسين اذا
بعد ما اعتقد هذه بعرف الدول قضيه مؤرقه
يعني طرق في طرق للاحتجاج في طرق للاحتجاج
السياسي والدبلوماسي اذا كان هذا المو
الموضوع يخالف
او يؤثر على العلاقات العراقيه الاردنيه
علما بانه القانون يعني يلزم الاحزاب
بالعمل داخل الاردن وان لا يتعرض هذا
العمل مع مصلحه الدوله هذا في قانون
الاحزاب الاردن لكن سيد واثق انتم
اسمح لي فقط ان تحول الاستاذ واثق انتم
تتحفظون على هذه النقطه والترخيص لحزب
البعث لكن في المقابل تقيمون علاقات مع
حزب البعث السوري
وساعدتوه على الصمود بعد ثوره 2011 في
سوريا وبالتالي كيف يمكن فهم هذه المقاربه
نعم يعني العراق لا يعترض على حزب البعث
سواء كان في سوريا او في السودان او في
غيره لكن في الاردن يعني هي ليست هذه
المره وليس حزب البعث فقط وانما اقيمت
اكثر من احتفاليه للتمديد بالنظام السابق
وهذا الحزب يعني انا قلت ارتبط تاريخ
الدموي من بدايته من بدايته الدمويه
بالانقلابات ثم قتل الرفاقه ثم
المقابر الجماعي وانتهاء بارتباطه بداعش
حتى الى اليوم وارتباطي بقطع علاقات
العراق معك كل الدول وبالتالي الاردن يعني
اليوم هل تقبل الاردن ان تسمح لاحزاب
معارضه للدول العربيه ان تمارس النشاط
وترفع صور معارضيها لهذه الدول العربيه لا
اعتقد انها تسمح
المشكله يعني المقاربه التي ذهب اليها
البعض في العراق كانت مقاربه لم تسعد
الاردنيين يعني بدا البعض البعض في العراق
يقول بانه الاردن دوله صغيره دوله فقيره
تعتمد على مساعدات وعليها ان تحرص ان تدرك
ما تفعل وتقوم به وكانه تهديد يعني هذا
الاسلوب الذي تم انتهاجه مع الاردن البعض
استهجنوا بشكل كبير خصوصا بانه هذه الخطوه
لم تكن موجه ضد العراق لكن فاما كثيرون
بانها ضد العراق استاذ سميح كيف تعلق على
هذا الامر
يعني من حق العراقيين يعني يعلقوا على كذا
باعتبار يعني اولا تربطنا مصالح حسن جوار
يعني مع الاردن ومصالح والعراق يعطيه حتى
نفطه تخفيض بالنسبه
تفضل تفضل الاردن هذا هذا هذا تاريخ سياسي
الاردن وقفته مع العراقيين واصدقائه ووقفه
طويله بكل المجالات انا ما بدي اتحدث فيها
وهذا واجبنا كاردنيا وبنقدر للعراقيين
وقفاتهم الطويله مع الاردن ومع العرب
بفلسطين ولكن اي حدا اي طرف يتحدث بمنا عن
الاردن الاردن لا يعيش على المساعدات
العراقيه الاردن يرتبط بعلاقات مصالح
مشتركه بينه وبين العراق نحن نقدم وهم
يقدمه احنا بنستفيد وهم يستفيدوا لذلك
المنطق للبعض بيتحدد فيه وكاننا بنتسول
على ابواب الحزب الفلاني والبليشيا
الفلانيه هذا منطق لا يليق بعلاقات الدول
نحن دوله بيننا وبين العراق عمر طويل احنا
على حدود ط اذا سمحت لي اكثر من 180 كم
تحديات مشتركه في وقفات عزم مشترك يعني
بعبر التاريخ بيننا فلا يليق باحده ما حدا
يحكي بهذا المنطق الذي الذي لا يليق احنا
حريصين على العراق احنا واقفين مع العراق
والعراق وقف معنا طويلا هذا حدا اليوم حزب
زي ما قلت لك بيحكي برفع صوره زعيم الى
اخره هذه قصه انا بعتقد الدول الراسخه
الدول القويه لا تهزها لا واحد رفع صوره
ولا رافع واحد رافع شعر احنا اليوم لما
بصير ازمه بفلسطين الاردنيين منحازين
لقضايا امتهم هسا اللي بيرفع شعار عراقي
بيزعج العراقيين يا سيدي يحتج سياسيا عبر
الدوله
انت قلت بانكم لست ضد حزب البعث منطقه
تهديد والمنه لا يحق لاحد ان يتحدث فيه مع
الاردن لانه نحن نتبادل المصالح والمنافع
عبر العقود فقط طيب انتم قلتم بانكم لستم
ضد الحزب البعث لكن هناك تيار قوي جدا في
العراق ضد ربما احاله قانون الشباك البعث
الى البرلمان والتخلص منه لماذا تصرون على
هذا القانون الذي خلف شرخا كبيرا داخل
العراق ويعني وحتى
الكثيرون والكثير الامريكيين يعتبرون بانه
كان خطا كبير ان يتم حل الجيش
وسن قانون اشتات البعث
يعني اولا هو قانون واحد من قوانين
الانتقاليه الذي يعني من المفترض ان تنتهي
كل احكامها باعتبار يعني بعض الاحكام هي
متعلقه بالحقوق شخصيه لمواطنين وجرائم
كبيره ارتكبت من هذا النظام ثم يعني كل
القاده وكل يعني تم استثنائهم يعني سوى من
قاده الجيش وهم الان يمارسون عملا بشكل
طبيعي
يعني غير مشمول اعداد كبيره من من قيادات
حزب البعث يعني الكل يقدر الوضع العراقي
وكيف كان نظام يجبر القاده العسكريين
والاساتذه والموظفين بصوره عامه على
الانخراط بحزب البعث بالتالي اليوم
التهديد الذي يشعر به العراق يعني من
الاردن باعتباره يحتضن كبار قاده حزب
البعث وهؤلاء يتدخلون في الشيء العراقي
ومساله رفع الصور او رفع الشعارات او
التهديد يعني فقط وكل العمليات حاولت على
هذه النقطه هؤلاء القاده يعني قاده حزب
الدعوه بانهم جاؤوا الى العراق على ظهر
الدبابه الامريكيه والتعاونه حتى مع ايران
وبالتالي ما فعل في الاردن هو رفع صوره
لصدام لكن عمليا حزب الدعوه
ازال نظاما موجودا وحل محله بالتعاون مع
دول كانت عدوه للعراق كيف تردون على هذا
الامر
يعني اولا حزب الدعوه لم ياتي على ظهر
ذبابه طبعا شيء ثاني يعني هو المجتمع
الدولي الكل كان متفق على اسقاط هذا
النظام الديكتاتوري الذي اساء ممارسه
الحكم اساء يعني اضطهد حقوق الانسان بشكل
كبير والمقابر الجماعيه الان لحد الان في
العراق بعد عشرين سنه لحد الان تكتشف
مقابر جماعيه وعبادات جماعيه والجرائم بحق
الكرد والسنه والشيعه وكل العراق من اقصاء
الى اقصاه بالاضافه الى ادخال يعني فقط
انت تكون بانه لم ياتي على ظهر دبابه لكن
من وضع هذا القانون هو بول بريمر يعني وهو
حاكم امريكي وايضا المالكي كان يعمل من
دول اقليميه ضد العراق وانت تتحدث عن رفع
اعلام انا اترك ربما مساحه الاستاذ سامح
المعايطه للرد على هذه النقطه
السيده اولا انا المشكله هاي ثاني مره
بطلع مع اخوان عراقيين ومش مدركين انه هذا
حزب مواطنين اردنيين نحن لا نحتضن قاده
حزب البعث العراقيين هذول العراقيين في
بلادهم او في اي مكان هذا حزب اردنيين لا
يجوز ومره ثانيه لا يحق لاحد ان يفرض
علينا من نرخص ومن لا نرخص ولا ان يضبط
احد خارج الحدود
احزابنا شو تحكي وشو ما تحكي احنا الدوله
الاردنيه تحاسب المواطن اذا خطا فيه
بالقانون الاردني نص يمنع اي حزب اردني من
الارتباط بالخارج فانا بعتقد وانا بدي
اقول لك اياها بصراحه قبل ما نختم كل هذه
الضجه من ايران ايران متضرره من علاقات
عربيه عراقيه قويه كل هذه الضجه لتعطيل
هذه العلاقات انا بتمنى ما بدي ادخل
بالشان العراقي ولا بدي اتحدث بالمنطقه
اللي حكيت فيه بالموضوع لكن انا بتمنى انه
كل واحد يديروا بالهم على دولتهم على
حالهم على مواطنينهم ويترك الدول نحن دوله
يعني امورنا وندرك من يفعل الخطا ومن يفعل
الصحابه اما حدا ميليشيا تتبع للحرس
الثوري تطلع مظاهره في بغداد ضد الدوله
الاردنيه لان رقصت حزب هذا ما بيطلع لهم
لا هم ولا اسيادهم فارجو ان يغلق هذا
الملف وان يوقفوا هذا البالون اللي
بينفقوا فيه وهذا الافتعال لازمه غير
موجوده ابحثوا عن قضيه اخرى فيها منطق
وليس بهذه القضايا الشكليه التي يعني لم
يعد فيها منطق وليس فيها حقائق هذا حزب
اردني مرخص من 30 سنه اجى صحيته اليوم
وتفطنتوا انه هذا الحزب حزب بعد فلما انت
يعني القصه هذا ما بينفع انت عليك ان تفكر
بنفسك وما تفكر حالك انه انت بحكم
ارتباطاتك انك تستطيع ان تقول للاردن افعل
او لا تفعل من يقول لك افعل او لا تفعل
انت يعني تعلم جيدا نحن نعلم من ورد
وقضيه لق ضيه مفتعله من الدرجه الاولى وما
في قصه اسمها عراقيين في حزب البعث
الاردني بدنا نفهمهم هذول الاردنيين
بمارسوا عمل سياسي ضمن القانون والدستور
الاردني يا اخواني افهموها ما العلاقه
رفعوا صوره لصدام اشتكوا عليهم عند
الحكومه الاردنيه وانتهت لا بدها مظاهرات
ولا مسيرات ولا الاردن يمارس العداله
مع العراق في كل المراحل اتفضل اسمع رد
الاستاذ واثق تفضل اسف على الاطاله لا
بسيطه
نعم يعني اولا يعني رفع الصوره هي انا قلت
له ليست الاولى شيء ثاني هذا الحزب تاسسه
هو دليل واضح يعني من خلال ممارساته
وشعاراته والدعاءاته كلها يعني دليل على
انه وجود المجرمين البحتين الموجودين في
الاردن هم يدعمون هذا الحزب ويمشق المباشر
وهذا واضح وبشكل علني والاردن هي كدوله
اليوم يعني يعني
لا يمكن لها ان تسمح لاي حزب مجرم في دوله
من الدول العربيه وفي اي دوله من العالم
ليس فقط الدول العربيه ان يمارس العمل
السياسي على ارضاه او او الهاربين من هذا
يعني المطلوبين لدول مجاوره العراق بلد
مجاور مطلوبين لهذه الدول
يعني القانون الاردني لا يسمح للعراقيين
بالانضمام الى حزب اردني
يا اخي اليوم هم هم الان يرفع
ون هم عراقي يعني اذا كانوا عراقيين
يرفعون سوء لصدام ما دخل الاردن بهذا
الامر
ممارسه يتحدثون عن
العراق يعني من مفطر ان يحترم العراق
الحكومه الاردنيه المفترض ان تحاسب هذا
الحزب وان تمنعهم الممارسه العمل السياسي
باعتبار اساء الى دوله جاره واصبح خطرا
على دوله جاره ونحن نعرف
العمليات الارهابيه التي حدثت في العراق
بعضها بدعم من بحثين سواء في الاردن او
غيرهم
شكرا لكم تماما كان معي من بغداد واثق
الجابري للباحث السياسي والشكر موصول ايضا
لضيفي من عمان سميح المعيط وزير الاعلام
الاردني الاسبق شكرا جزيلا لكما
فانورام انتهت شكرا لكم على متابعه والى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات